[Music]
what did some of these screen
tests you filmed in england consist of
what did you do in them
i haven't seen them i don't know how
they look like what is it um but so we
went there
we were together for the first test
there was a there was another one
where we had to try
the most dramatic scene in the movie
when it's like the breakup between
twitter and borah
that was the second one and i believe so
that third one was when i was alone and
they wanted to
test me if i'm alone in a room or in a
place with some people that's
pre-coveted when
covet wasn't happened so that's why we
were i said in a room
um if i'm alone am i gonna handle the
scene by myself because when sasha is
there
he's gonna save it forever uh but uh
so and i remember that um
[Music]
some of them advised me don't be like
clean don't
like prepare yourself to look pretty or
to be
clam or something try to not take shower
and i was like
oh okay i mean i'm ready for it but i'm
in the middle of another production so
it's gonna be devastating for the rest
of the crew in
in the movie that i'm shooting so i made
something super
smelly stinky with valeriana peels um
old eggs vinegar old olive oil
onions and i mixed it and it was
probably the worst smell that you can
ever imagine and i put it all over me
and i started like hugging and
touching people for bye and they're like
okay this is not an actor for sure
so that was probably the last audition
that i went and it
was yeah it was maybe two weeks before
i came to america and we started
shooting this
crazy beautiful world cluster